salut aujourd'hui on est jeudi c'est
donc le jour où je parle de ce que je
veux que ça fait très longtemps que vous
ai pas parlé de bouquins pas de bouquins
de mentalisme parce que le jeudi c'est
hors sujet hors sujet pas tout à fait
parce que je veux vous parler d'un
auteur que j'affectionne
particulièrement c'est bernard werber
j'ai rencontré cet auteur par le biais
de ses livres 1 uniquement dans le début
des années 90 quand j'étais au collège
il avait sorti un seul livre qui
s'appelait les fourmis à la base bernard
werber c'est un journaliste scientifique
et c'est quelqu'un qui a une grande
réflexion aussi spirituelle ce qui est
très intéressant c'est qu'il met tous à
l'intérieur de ces bouquins et en
parallèle de ça c'est un vrai auteur de
sf le résultat ça donne un artiste
littéraire vraiment complet j'ai jamais
été déçu par ce qu'il a produit par la
suite à part un livre et je vais vous
expliquer pourquoi son dernier bouquin
c'est le sixième sommeil dans la vidéo
que j'ai fait sur les rêves lucides vous
en parlait il ya eu les fourmis le cycle
des fourmis les fourmis le jour des
fourmis la révolution des fourmis et en
parallèle encyclopédie du savoir relatif
et absolu et le livre secret des fourmis
ça se ressemble un petit peu mais ça
c'est vraiment des années que ce roman
ça me met en parallèle plusieurs
histoires dont principalement celle d'un
groupe d'humains et celle d'un groupe de
fourmies dit comme ça ça paraît chelou
mais on apprend énormément de choses il
ya aussi un point commun dans tous ses
livres c'est qu'il ya toujours une
impossibilité qu'il va falloir résoudre
aussi bien dans l'histoire que par le
biais d'une énigme plus tard il a écrit
aussi une pathologie mentale augis pas
un livre sur les pantalons les
thanatonautes lempire des anges nous les
dieux le souffle des dieux et le mystère
des dieux ces cinq livres dont le point
de départ c'est un groupe de personnes
qui cherche à explorer la mort à
découvrir ce qu'il ya après la mort et
tout ça est imprégné de toutes les
religions de toutes les croyances qui a
eu de la mythologie de l'egypte de
science fiction de réflexion de choses
qu'on apprend sur les autres sur
nous-mêmes et la houle est très malin et
c'est un grand auteur c'est qu'en plus
on récupère des personnages de l'univers
des fourmis qui viennent se mêler aux
thanatonautes pour se retrouver après
dans l' empire des anges et dont nous
les durand journaliste scientifique il a
écrit aussi sur la science il est le
premier qui les fait dans ce genre là je
crois que c'est les pères de nos pères
donc c'est un bouquin qui traite du
chaînon manquant et comme souvent dans
les livres de bernard werber il ya deux
histoires en parallèle celle qui se
déroule pendant la préhistoire et celle
qui se déroule à notre époque
dans le même genre il avait fait
l'ultime secret qui est un livre sur
quelqu'un qui a découvert la motivation
ultime quelle est la plus grande façon
de motiver un être humain il ya aussi un
côté polar derrière tout ça hein pas un
polar de sf mais surtout on cherche quel
est notre propre source de motivation
durant livre
une fois on apprend beaucoup sur nous
même et toujours dans ce style
d'écriture elle a écrit le rire du
cyclope qui est un formidable livre sur
le rire d'où vient le rire le plus du
livre qui est très drôle c'était hyper
culotté d'écrire là-dessus sait d'où
viennent les blagues les blagues et
celle que tout le monde connaît les
blagues universelle qui les écrit doit
ce qu'elles viennent et déjà est ce
qu'il ya quelqu'un qui les écrit pour
ceux qui aiment les nouvelles il a aussi
écrit deux livres de nouvelles l'arbre
des possibles et et paradis sur mesure
je suis très friand de nouvelles depuis
le jour j'ai découvert dino buzzati le
livre le cas et à cet exercice très
compliqué que sont les nouvelles il s'en
sort extrêmement bien dans certaines
nouvelles on pressent le roman qui peut
arriver c'est ce qui s'est passé avec le
rire du cyclope en notre trilogie il
écrit aussi troisième humanité après
quand votre libya le livre du voyage qui
est un essai très particulier parce que
c'est un livre qui nous parle à nous au
lecteur directement il a également écrit
nos amis les humains qui est une pièce
de théâtre le papillon des étoiles qui
est mon livre préféré
autant j'aime vraiment la globalité du
travail les trilogies autant le papillon
des étoiles jeu j'ai dû lire trois
quatre fois en fait tellement il était
inspirant et inspiré il se passe sur des
centaines et des centaines d'années il
ya un rythme dans la progression de
l'histoire qui qui arrive à nous
surprendre qui bouge il ya un rythme
aussi dans la temporalité qui est très
intéressant un certain point il m'a fait
penser aussi à des scénarios de films
comme la planète des singes il ya juste
un livre je vous ai dit tout à l'heure
le miroir de cassandre ça n'a pas marché
sur moi je suppose que si quelqu'un ne
connaissais pas cet auteur elysées le
miroir de cassandre
il adorerait y avait un défaut j'avais
l'impression d'une redondance de tout ce
que j'avais pu apprendre en dehors de
l'histoire en elle même de tout ce que
j'avais pu apprendre dans ses autres
livres que ce soit en termes de
réflexion de culture générale de
concepts spirituel je trouvais que
c'était une espèce de redondance de
résonance de tout ce qui existait déjà
même si j'ai bien conscience que pour
quelqu'un qui n'ait jamais lu de werber
il doit trouver ce bouquin passionnant
de fait puisqu'il reprend tous les
concepts qu'on a vu déjà dans les autres
livres j'ai l'impression que cette
personne a un projet global derrière
tout son univers artistique de
transmission de quelque chose et dans
ses livres j'ai l'impression de le
rencontrer lui alors je me suis dit
aujourd'hui celle aujourd'hui hors sujet
ou le dis ce que je veux mais je parle
de mon auteur préféré
la plupart des livres que je vous ai
cités sauf les très récents qui sont
disponible en livre de poche il se
trouve dans les bibliothèques dans les
médiathèques je suis sûr que dans votre
entourage il ya des gens qui lisent du
bernard werber et vous pouvez emprunter
les livres comme ça pour pouvoir les
lire
c'est pas une vidéo pour vous
cité à les acheter il se trouve très
facilement vous pouvez vous les faire
prêter j'en suis certain et si vous n'en
avez jamais lus et que vous n'êtes pas
prêt à partir sur une trilogie ou
quelque chose comme ça l'elysée le
papillon des étoiles merci beaucoup à
vous d'avoir regardé cette vidéo
n'oubliez pas de laisser un petit
commentaire je répondre à tous les
commentaires de la semaine ce week end
ça faisait assez longtemps que j'avais
pas fait une vidéo sur des bouquins je
crois que j'avais pas fais ça depuis le
mois de février ou mars
donc si ça vous a plu n'hésitez pas à me
le faire savoir en laissant un petit
pouce en l'air on sait également à vous
abonner à la chaîne en cliquant sur le
petit logo sous la vidéo sur abonnez
vous puisque le mental bob c'est une
vidéo par jour pendant un an donc rendez
vous demain à 17h ciao
oui